[Music]
everybody going
in wake up early in the morning press
play and let's get it in cause we
rocking with the fighter and he
[Music]
[Laughter]
i brought that pick yeah i brought this
yeah you you had some
uh cajones my man showing you cause
you're taking are you gonna do before
and after pics yeah
i got it man i got i gotta i gotta be
honest with myself that's the only way i
can be honest with myself about it
i yeah i mean for you to send the group
chat your
before pics is brave oh yeah it's brave
you haven't he said
james jj was all being nice jesus
there's a lot of muscle under there man
he can do this
he said what that gut do baby
it's so funny because i was driving and
i just see the text pop up on my
uh screen and i'm like what that gun do
baby
chappelle was brave but yeah it would
take a lot of weight to do that but i
had to be honest with myself body
shaming works man
i have to dude i have to like understand
like yo
you don't [ __ ] look good yeah you
could look better than that you had step
daddy sweatpants
step daddy sweat pants on and everything
bro the little champion logo used on the
prison picker
that's all i know and your girl who took
them that's like that that's my first
question like who takes them yeah
because my my head my girl take them
she's like i think you look fine i'm
like that's the problem that's the
problem i'm an enabler yeah i don't feel
fun
yeah i know i don't look fine yeah you
know you don't look fine i know i don't
look fine i know i don't [ __ ] look
for when you see the pigs that's right
like
god damn i look like that did you do the
side one yeah that's why i didn't sit
down
that santa claus side
did you take one from the back you got
that muffin top at the back
oh would it come in like the love
handles do baby ah i did not take one
from the back
i didn't know you supposed to take it
from the back yes like back like this
from real inside we're all sad i'll be
pissed as [ __ ] my girl like oh go
show me your motherfucks flex big man
i think you look fine i know right no
[ __ ] no yeah i
i just i don't know yeah i went
snowboarding over the
weekend for the first time and like your
first time ever snowboarding
first time every ass i bet is so sore uh
yeah yeah my ass
but like uh like just how exhausted i
was and like just so easily
squeezing and [ __ ] yeah like i was like
[ __ ] and then like
there's a way you stand up on the
snowboard like from like if you fall in
your ass you there's a way you stand up
yeah
yeah you're supposed to pull your feet
in whatever blah blah blah i could not
[ __ ] do that but i had to roll to my
stomach
meanwhile i got this big ass board i ate
it off the [ __ ] lift yeah
yeah i was trash you just gotta do it
more yeah that's right
you just gotta do it more but like i was
i was frustrated but it but like
i was mainly mad about like my [ __ ]
physical your endurance
yeah it was just trash i'm like what the
[ __ ] am i doing you got some willpower
too cause you came over to tiger's fifth
birthday party
we had that calabasas steve irwin up in
that [ __ ] yeah that's oh yeah that
calabasas steve
receiver he came through but then uh you
when the porto's desserts came out you
said
all right dog i'm out yo i had to take
out i really did
i really yeah bro i'm telling you i
think i really do have a food addiction
oh me too because how many days have you
been on like a strict
like be honest strict i'd say probably
like four days yeah
you gotta get past like that eight or
nine days how long have you been on
he's been on it for like a week way
longer since
uh february 10th okay 21st
but yeah man it's it's [ __ ] tough i i
literally
i'm addicted to the food i had to walk
away i was like yeah yeah i can't yeah
you called it quits
yeah i had to call it yeah i got out of
there good for you they started cutting
up the mario cake bruh that [ __ ] was
pretty
good everywhere cake pops everywhere do
this this guy
ladies just like every time like
everywhere oh bringing out a new there
was what was those things kind of
brothers
were they cuban yeah the cuban portas
cuban portuguese those are the dark
roads
bro back in the day are they eight of
those for real bro that cream filling in
it
[ __ ] lava and glitter and cheese
yeah it was [ __ ] tough dude i could i
couldn't do it that's me and tiger on
our b day hike
oh look at that he was so excited man he
did he did so good with
holding them damn uh reptiles and [ __ ]
yeah man calabasas steve irwin
yeah he came out with that accent and
then when he talked to me i'm like that
hey y'all you're australian he's like
nah man
you say no i just do that for the kids
man it gets me in the mood puts me in
the vibe of the whole thing
yeah and then he uh yeah look at theo's
thing play this chin yeah
here we go
[Laughter]
i didn't like that stuff oh yeah brenda
was not about that [ __ ] snake
don't eat it don't eat him
yeah there's calabasas steve herbert
yeah cowboy you little too loosey-goosey
with them
animals he told me so he dropped the
accent because he started pulling out
all the animals
and then i was like you're from
australia man i was like i've been out
there he's like nah man
he's on from the valley bro i just do
that to getting character for the kids i
was like
oh that's cool and then he's like man
that that albino boat constricted your
son's hole and he's like
bro few months ago i think it was wild
man because that thing was super most
aggressive animal you've ever seen bubba
yeah what while you're while you're
waiting while people were holding it was
being
like people were like yeah it was going
around it went to you
he was like you know i just broke it
down with with kindness man look at him
now i was like
how long ago he's like a few months ago
man i think it was wild i couldn't bring
around anybody but me he just bit me a
few times
i was like what the [ __ ] i didn't feel
comfortable with it oh [ __ ] that's my
girl it was his stuff it was like did
you sign an insurance
waiver or some [ __ ] yeah this thing
starts popping off on kids what are we
gonna do man
he was so trustworthy we're letting the
kids like hold the [ __ ]
walk away tarantulas rancho snakes yeah
and austin was like yeah boston just was
looking at like hit the snake like whoa
too much amigo but then there was one
[ __ ] kid like poking their eyes
oh yeah yeah i won yeah like someone
needs to get this [ __ ] kid
yeah and then his uh he's just the baby
and i was hoping that the animal would
buy it and teach him a lesson yeah that
one was a baby kid i was like this
brother needed a chill yeah
he was he was the one he was that one
he's driving nuts there's always one kid
like yeah
when it was uh calabasas steve berman
said all right now don't touch this one
on the ted he
touched him on the head i mean i don't
believe him what does he know he touched
him on the head and then noticed
calabasas steve irwin wouldn't let that
kid touch the spider he's like no he
went now this one don't have a shell
yeah that's why i have a shell you hit
him too hard it's really
[ __ ] very fragile very fragile yeah
thank you
some frost toads horn lizard yeah a
monitor
a monitor lizard yep he had some [ __ ]
reptiles come out bro
yeah that's insane he did like an hour
yeah he did an hour he did like an hour
set bro
he kept doing joe oh then he was he
would come around all the parents too
and let him touch the animal
they got to theo and was like theo's
friend who we brought she was like
what's he eat he's like
eggs because they can't run he's like
look at this like you can keep that one
yeah you winked up i'm going to wink so
you keep thinking
i like the feeling man this guy's
bombing
it was kind of cool i [ __ ] with
reptiles yeah yeah it was fun yeah it
was fun
he didn't [ __ ] with that snake i didn't
trust that did you you didn't find the
other snake the python
now i don't know you know my thing with
snakes i see the rattlesnake you see on
the road all the time
on the trails when i mountain bike or
bike ride but those are different than a
rattlesnake bro they're different but
also when he told me how aggressive that
snake was just a few months ago i'm
uncomfortable
and then it started going up my face and
then there's one older kid there and the
snake started
the snake oh yeah started poking that
yeah poking at you i'm like bro get your
[ __ ] snake
yes where watch the whole thing go down
and then and then the little what were
y'all doing and then the little bow
constrictor went around tiger's neck and
i was like bro he's around his neck and
all the parents are like oh he's
wrapping around your son's neck
and then the guy's like dude all the
parents freak out when the snake wraps a
little kid's neck he's like
don't worry about it i can pull that
thing right off oh yeah he's like what
you got to worry about
is that thing starts biting it's getting
about 10 bites and before i get to it
that's what it is
bro that's suffocation yeah tiger was
like it's like a backpack
[Laughter]
did not know it was like he's like it
was crazy
that's so funny this was wild with it
insurance policy because this thing
starts wilding the [ __ ] out going back
to the rainforest days
yeah just buying these kids like i want
no liability because he didn't initially
pull it out he just lifted up the
[ __ ]
at the top of the box and that [ __ ] just
[ __ ] oh immediately
it just took off tiger was like uh just
grabbed him
yeah [ __ ] you've never seen
hercules when the baby when the two
snakes saying grab them he's like
it was it was pretty crazy it was dope
yeah it was dope though man it's cool
damn all right they had domino's pizza i
looked at it said nope he said no i said
not today
you saw what i was eating cauliflower
yeah cauliflower chicken
by yourself yeah hot sauce rice
cauliflower rice and chicken chicken and
hot sauce that's it that's it brother
stayed on that yeah
for dinner i had lean uh beef lean beef
and uh brussels sprouts yeah okay yeah
water what did i have for i have had uh
egg whites and spinach with grilled
chicken which was really good how many
times do you eat a day um
i do three meals i did three three
snacks three meals three snacks oh yeah
so what do you do what do you do for
snacks
snacks i'll do uh an apple with uh
almond butter okay nice
yeah [ __ ] yeah you gotta be careful with
that almond butter a ton of calories in
it
is it really so cute but it probably you
probably map it out
that's what i'm saying you can only have
two tablespoons got it so that was gonna
you ever seen two tablespoons
two [ __ ] tablespoons that's it you
know how big an apple is
how big oh pretty [ __ ] two tables
yeah
two tablespoons when you run out of that
[ __ ] what are you gonna do with that
yeah [ __ ] sounds depressed i know now
you're just scraping the spoon
trying to find extra butter it's sad
it is sad it's tough it'll be weird
[ __ ] got it it'll be so [ __ ]
oh you you went to zoo culture oh i went
to zoo culture without yeah we both went
and you went without me
yep i went with mark dawg how was it
looking out there bro
i bought merchant [ __ ] that's wrong guys
that [ __ ] yeah
in his color you know i i would have got
black but i was like hey they only have
the tan for you
no no they had they oh yeah but i was
just like all right let me do something
different
it's bigger now is this size big this is
xl oh okay
that's what you wear oh you were
actually not that big oh it makes you
look big
here's here's here's the real test
here's the real test chappelle
real testimony when you're in kansas
city and i'm in tampa it's all fun and
games when you're at home
on schedule we hit that road life no
you can't get the meals shout out to
kansas city fans
because they've been messaging me
showing me healthier spots
in the area hell yeah so i got this i'm
so [ __ ] excited i just need to find a
[ __ ] gym out there i got to work
out though because i i want to stay on
that i don't want to like not
do that are you going to try to work out
uh maybe i'll go for a run or something
but it's all diet dude diets
95 percent of it but i love that i'm
more worried about the diet
more worried about the diet really less
about the gym more
diet's definitely far more important
than the gym
is that what they say that's what
everybody says
it was well i mean but if you can mix it
in there
more power to you but the diet you
really got to stick on in kansas city
just look at that picture
that you sent i know i got to look at
that that pic i was brave
that was pretty [ __ ] brave yeah i
said that to the bros dog
like robert harris [ __ ] you
bro you say what what that gun do baby
i saw you song
jay was being all nice jay's all the way
to dating
he's all dude you shed those pounds
there's some serious muscle
[Laughter]
some serious muscle under there yeah
it's i mean this is i kind of want to
look at the picture but
ah bro let it go no wait wait to show
the audience
the fans until you so i hit the after
yeah that's when i'll show them before
what's your goal that's the [ __ ]
what's your goal again
uh well you got the [ __ ] scale oh
yeah i bought the skill yeah yeah i
bought the scale electric
but your other ideal weights what 225
should that be i little if i was 225.
by literally means shredded yeah 225
that's where you'll meet me at 25.
yeah meet you at 22. [ __ ] you
ain't getting no 225 180 right now
you're not you're not 180. okay you're
not one eight you're not one eight i
just well you gotta scale
i borrow my skin yeah you gotta get it
out after 180 and we'll get it out
my my problem too is gonna be because i
shoot that show food truck diaries
those food trucks you can figure it out
yeah like today we got max hallway on we
got fried chicken so i'll just take the
skin off yeah
yeah yeah that's protein yeah i like it
dolce helps you map that [ __ ] out to
where it's like
okay if you're going to eat this then
you got to do this for the rest of the
day yup
see yeah that's good though yeah it
should be all right
i was watching 600 pound life this
weekend oh guess what i drove stick for
the first time
really really yeah yeah fun right nah it
feels annoying
it really it's tough oh my god i just i
parked the car what car were you driving
oh the tc the little uh i don't know
what kind of car was that it was my
friends
you never drove stick before i never
drove there no bro you got to keep i was
like
y'all drop stick nope oh yeah chin never
mind so much
they're watching it was one of those the
first ones chin this one yeah
was your civic stick hell yeah yeah yeah
that's what you want
yeah in certain cars you want stick yeah
my first car was a stick and then it was
valet
like you have to that's one of the
[ __ ] requirements you gotta learn how
to drive stick that's just frustrating i
parked the car so many times
it's a beast if you don't were you
stalling out too yeah i didn't know what
to do
once you get out of that first though go
from there
well it really is i think so the start's
the toughest part like
when you hit red lights and stop signs
yeah
[Applause]
form a sports car that's that drives
yeah yeah and you can
porsche uh has a a gt3 that's did you
report triggers
yeah pdk pdk's what does that mean that
that oh that's the winners yeah they're
fast because all computers no human
error
oh really so even with like the best
driver if you have pdk you're gonna beat
the best driver
i was watching some video i don't know
what kind of car went because i don't
know the racing stuff
but it was like it was like three things
three pedals i think in the stake yeah i
know what you're talking about
gas and clutch yeah it was it was some
race race car driver he was like
it was still like it was over at the
bottom it's three pedals yeah yeah yeah
i don't know what car
would that be that's your clutch gas and
break
no no no sorry was it three
no what was it stop right i know i
[ __ ] up you say there's four now
no not three four man there's a fourth
in there
that's how they look dude there's no
four there's no four oh okay that's
your break your gas and your clutch yeah
[ __ ] okay the way that dude's feet was
moving i thought he had four things
that makes sense these are plates that
look like you might have wrestled
okay okay okay that's what okay yeah
but that's all those race car drivers
that's what they have under there yeah
like nascar is a little weird though
right because they have like they do
multiple things
or like rally cars i'll look it up right
now though the
rally card was a rally car they're in
like in the dirt they haul ass
oh really like a navigator yeah yeah
wait jay said you could snowboard
yeah i grew up snowboarding that's i
mean that makes sense snowboarding was
my daycare son
oh really colorado that's what me my dad
would do when i was since i was little
i didn't i didn't skiing wasn't even
wasn't even an idea
like when i was younger snowboarding
would just start popping
and i got a used snowboard from playing
against sports shots yeah shout outs
yeah so i it was a sims board of sick
uh-huh all the time
you go down that [ __ ] hill and
[ __ ] i don't know about i'm sure i could
it's like riding a bike hopefully i'm
sure i could now yeah you probably still
i just do it all the time
yeah that was the thing with me was with
snowboarding like i was just like
like with yeah it's too much of a hassle
too much too much i was like driving
there
yes listen i'm thirsty i hate the lift
now i'm 34 years old
yeah i don't need to learn anything new
extreme right now well i don't i don't
need it you don't want to get hurt
yeah like with skateboarding is
different i've been doing i've been
doing that since i was a kid
so it's it's completely [ __ ]
different but snowboarding i'm like i'm
trying to learn how to do this and once
you get going faster
you hit your head or something i was
[ __ ]
what it ain't worth it man i was crying
my buddy had to catch me like several
times was your buddy good
yeah he's good yeah you should have took
me i'm great you can snowboard like a
snowboard i don't believe that
bro i go to boog bear every every other
look there
we need to get your books yeah we need
to get your books on
yeah is that a bootleg [ __ ] big bear
mountain or something it's a dope ass
cabin out there yeah yeah i get a
snowboard growing up in
new orleans no i was out here for since
2015. oh here
and then we go to your family to take
you to a book fair yo yes
yeah i gotta send pictures now i gotta
everything i don't understand why y'all
don't believe me
okay but maybe you've done it i think
yeah you're great
i'm great at snowboarding i don't i just
don't buy that okay all right
whatever oh cat i watched that
documentary on it's good right
oh what the most i was disappointed at
the end
really i like the ending spoiler in
three two one
so it's it's on the not the night
stalker on the
zodiac killer yeah this guy who was
adopted
as he got older he started to put two
and two together
and realized that he thought his dad was
the zodiac killer which they've never
caught
got it so he linked up with this lady to
write a book
and has all this evidence saying that
his dad's zodiac killer
and then so the whole documentary i go
[ __ ] is and they're lining everything up
like
99 dna tests fingerprints his dad was
here when the murder happened here so he
put it all together and
my girl goes do you think his dad's
really the zodiac killer i'm like yeah
man look at all the facts he has
and then i started thinking i'm like if
he really solved this case it would be
all over the news i haven't seen any of
that
so wikipedia the zodiac killer his dad's
not associated with it
then the last episode they have
detectives like break down all his [ __ ]
that's not the zodiac killer man no is
that any and he likes he's there
he like just some [ __ ] who ditched
him so he like
he likes like lied about all these facts
in the case to the writer
yeah but he made it seem like it was
actual evidence so she wrote
the the book that it was his dad and
she's like oh it's the his dad was
100 zodiac killer if you don't have
the backings of actual science and
evidence you would think his dad's the
killer
because he gave her all this evidence
yeah dude she found out he was lying and
made up all this [ __ ]
she was so pissed and he had a book
released on it big time
it was one of uh he's upset about zodiac
killer
too so when it came out it was huge he
was obsessed with zodiac killer and
he it was his way of making his dad in
this monster why he gave him up
and he like formed failed marriages like
all this [ __ ] what
yeah yeah because you're so obsessed
with it and then you find out like dude
your dad's not there to kill you just an
[ __ ] but i think that's exhausting
it was his way of dealing with his dad
leaving him yeah my dad's the killer
like
my dad's famous zodiac killer that's why
he did this to me
no no dude your dad's just a bad person
not the killer
but what about like so they they solved
all of it the this they had a private
investigator on it and they can now they
can track back
you know where your dad was certain
during the killing stuff and during the
times when the zodiac killer was killing
his dad was in austria it wasn't even in
the united states
there's no documentary to be had it was
a complete waste of time
we got done that last episode what the
[ __ ]
you waited
and then the fourth [ __ ] episode a
real detective gets on there
and he told the author they met with the
detective and detective
goes yeah we're pretty sure for a fact
that your dad's 99 percent
dna match to the zodiac kill your dad's
probably a killer
the author meets with the investor he's
like i never said that
he's like i told him with the evidence
that we have
that we can't like just say your dad's
not the killer but
there's so many people with matches yeah
yeah there's thousands of people who can
match this
wow he took that changed it told the
author one thing she's like go damn he's
the killer
did he get in trouble for that [ __ ] uh i
don't think he got in trouble it's just
now people know him as a fraud
he's all defending and [ __ ] on there
there was that moment when they caught
him in the lie
so he's trying to like justify his way
around it white on camera
they uh asked him about the dna evidence
that he said he
like links his father to being the
zodiac killer so so for the listeners so
he got his dna evidence they put up the
dna like
strand on tv but it's tv
and they're not going to release the
actual dna of the zodiac killer so they
just put up a
general strand saying he he matches
these
you know like yeah it's just a graphic
for example it's not the actual
yeah he took that as verbatim
and matched his dad's dna to that but
the detectives are like
we would never put the actual dna on tv
for everybody to see
like we can't do that legally so he's
matching to a fake dna strand
so this the the the detective like so
this whole documentary is a waste of
time this is the time
dude we got done with my girls like ah
four nights of this [ __ ] is this on
netflix
oh fx start on fx yeah i feel like this
netflix would be killing the game
it's it's good but when you know that
the whole like now
listeners like it's completely waste
time the first three episodes
this guy trying to convince his dad he
might as well say his dad's michael
jordan
oh he's not mad so it was four hours of
him just basically saying i want my dad
in my life
it's four hours him validating why his
dad left him
like four hours of him trying to make it
make his dad more of a
like terrible person to justify why he
left like i think he never got over the
fact that he was adopted even though
he was adopted at like as a
four-month-old baby
to like a his dad left him in the
hallway
yeah just left them and then this family
a very very like nice family from the
midwest adopted him they had their own
kid so he had like a very complete
family he grew up with a good because he
very good family very loving supportive
he owns like a business has like
yeah he's successful but for some reason
he always felt like
he needed some sort of explanation to
why his parents
left him why is
he met up with his mom and his mom was
like dude i'm telling you your dad's not
this way
so his mom was even saying it and his
his mom and him were strange because he
kept pitching that was the right kill
he's like
dude your dad is not that like i have
letters to back
this up and she's like i read the book i
got through the first two chapters and
he exaggerated on so much [ __ ] like none
of it's real
damn perpetrating a fraud [ __ ]
yeah it was weird it was where you get
done with those four and you're like
[ __ ]
dude really [ __ ] i was gonna buy the
book too
yeah you were right because if you know
about the book or you watch the series
without knowing anything
if you know the ending it's useless in
my opinion so if you know this
guy's a song don't waste your time yeah
i won't watch it i loved it you loved it
i loved it because i didn't know any of
this going into it it's like that last
episode that flips it
so it's nice but if you already knew how
it's gonna end
i think it's a complete if you know that
his dad's not the killer it's complete
waste of time i get i get why you're
annoyed with it because it's like it's
this lead up
to where you almost think oh this guy's
dead but i but
during episode one my girl's like man he
has all this evidence
my girl's like you really think his
dad's zoe killer and at first i was like
yeah i'm gonna start thinking like
that would be all over the news if they
caught the zoda if they figure out this
that was a big [ __ ] deal yeah
he's still on the loose he's probably 90
now he might be dead who knows
i think they caught him no never no
really i thought they caught him but
then he had already died by the time
like they found out who was ah that's a
good
golden state killer oh golden state yes
yes
zodiac they have no clue the newspaper
which one was that one golden state
killer just killed all all over up and
down
they like they composed uh actually uh
um patton oswald's uh wife who passed
away caught him
so there's history.com but zodiac
killers through accessory.com yup
through dna and ancestry.com
but zodiac killer is still out there
they you know obviously he's not he's
not killing anybody but
yeah he's out how many people did uh
zodiac killer
i think confirmed like five or six but
he says like
32.
that's a lot of kills and the same thing
that another thing that
my favorite podcast for like the past
six weeks is called apology the apology
line
was to start in new york people could
call in and get whatever they want off
their chest
and a serial killer started to call and
it got so juicy
because he called like tonight i mean
this lady and the the guy he was
anonymous the guy who ran the apology
line they called mr apology
he was like we'll send evidence and he
would send evidence of actual bodies
being
mutilated and all the [ __ ] and then
you're like oh damn people
you think that's real he's like pretty
real and he's like offers to meet with
the serial killer and all this [ __ ]
it gets great it's such a good podcast
that's okay all right
get ready episode six episode six
turns out that detectives uh because the
detective there there's killings going
on in new york especially back then in
the 90s there's all these
there's a serial killer on the loose so
they hit up mr apology he met with the
detectives
they got all the info on that serial
killer who's calling in i'll see their
detectives
they don't tell the apology line this
they track that guy down who's saying
he's a serial killer
they bring him in for investigation to
talk with him he says he made it all up
it's not real
oh so episode six he was like i was
never a serial killer
he was like i just thought it was gonna
be twice that's [ __ ]
this is so so mad i was like what
i invested in six weeks six weeks six
weeks of my life
six weeks and that's the six and all
that was fake
oh all of it was fake where do you go
from here like
and they say mr apology knew that and
still carried on he knew it
he knew it they just wanted clout of
course
he can't go on there like kp this is
fake because he ran the whole
apology line they made a movie off of it
hbo did a documentary on it like
there was all this [ __ ] on it and so he
just doubled down i was like
okay and then he passed away he was like
uh
snorkeling or scuba diving he got hit by
a uh jet ski and died
for lion no just life or maybe god was
like you know
yeah karma you know what he said maybe i
was like
i was like you know what you know i mean
we need to have a face to face because
you said
crazy huh killed the people crazy damn
that's [ __ ] crazy i know
his ex girls on there who's just like
yeah it was all fake and i was like
oh god wasn't it a movie uh the bone
collector or something like that where
he just sent in was like phone
collection with denzel washington and uh
angelina jolie yeah it was something
like that when he sent in he's in the
hospital
and the killer was saying let him know
like i'm about to kill tonight and stuff
like that that's
that's what this was but you could they
would play his actual collins
like i'm gonna kill these two gay guys
that's what i'm gonna do with them and
they would send fake pictures
yeah when you think it's real and you
hear the serial killer talking
and he sounds eerie as [ __ ] oh dude it's
nuts
it's [ __ ] did this [ __ ] get
in trouble for that
well there's not much legally there's
not much they can do especially all he's
doing is lying they they brought him in
was like what are you doing
and then under pressure he's like all
right i made it all up
damn i just think that you think there'd
be some [ __ ] law against that
no there's now but in the 90s there's
you know there's nothing
and what's a bummer is that mr apology
like this line was huge back then
yeah but because there's no social media
or like podcast at the time
yeah he wasn't making money off of it so
he sold the movie rights kind of sold
out
they had to start charging people to
call into the line because back then
there was like radio and then
what he was doing was like like miss
cleo kind of it was just tough man
yeah was clear they had to call in they
had to call in and just subscription yes
subscribe
yeah kind of yeah wasn't it i'm not
well yeah he wasn't psychic why are you
why are you trying to give me though
like he was like
yes you did no i did it that was a
stretch
though brendan i believe he called in
and i mean i mean the the
correlation there's i mean um
yeah but mr apology was complete full of
[ __ ] it was like number one podcast in
the world at the time
like three weeks ago and then this
[ __ ]
zodiac killer this [ __ ] guy dude your
dad just sucked so not everybody just
wants to make a [ __ ] documentary
sounds like
that [ __ ] was lit though for the first
three episodes first three episodes
live and it was on fx right start on fx
and came over to hulu you watched the
six nine one yet
i had on show time no jay did so it's
better than the one we watched on here
and the director of that uh showtime six
nine doc was like he's a terrible person
he was like he's the worst really yeah i
mean
it's something i don't know
he uh he i don't know he's just a weird
guy
honestly just a child i don't think he
knows
where to go from here and he doubled
down on being the bad guy so he has to
like
he has stomach yes he has to own it he
has to and he's like the most infamous
snitch of all time
since [ __ ] the john gotti case with
uh the bull guy
so it's like really you're the face of
it now man yeah
how many dudes did he send [ __ ] to get
sent to prison
and jay was saying they actually have
guys from treyway on here talking yeah
from the gang oh see that other one we
watched they didn't have any
no talking about showtime now big boy
[ __ ] also it's a great documentary on
fx called hip-hop uh uncovered have
y'all watched no i haven't watched that
one it's behind the scenes with what
goes on in hip hop so you ever heard
like check in like six and i have to
check in
it's a docker mini on the people that
you have to check in with so they have
like trick trick in detroit
you go to detroit oh like if you're
going to do a show yeah
like if you land let's say you got to
check in you got to go into a show la is
big you
puerto rican uh haitian jack is in new
york benny
all those in there let me check it like
if you're doing shows yeah like if
you're interested
in anybody [ __ ] my soul [ __ ] sold
cleveland this weekend is that all right
he's like i don't give a [ __ ]
but you're not yeah but the streets like
so the rappers they rapping though like
they're rapping about this life so
again they gonna be i mean hip hop
uncovered in 1990
is it it's reagan's bubble gum rap like
who's he gonna check in with this drink
and this isn't yeah yeah back then was
like actual gangster rap
yeah yeah not anymore no you know you'd
be a damn fool to check in now let's go
yeah they shot it soldier boys not
checking in with it nobody looking for
shoulder boys they were like yo i'm here
okay
good luck go on the radio man
what does he have to do with princess
die who uh benny
yeah uh i don't know we didn't get to
that point i think it's just a list of
things
to watch because steven yoon came out
i was like hold on this is a weird turn
yeah i was like i thought this was
hip-hop yeah that's probably you got to
check in back when
it was like gangster rap like yeah [ __ ]
like nwa
uh who else eminem had to check in uh
vig
a biggie he didn't check in before well
yeah he checked in pocket everyone
before gangster when it like mattered
yeah
all these guys but again it's like now
it's just a bunch of fake [ __ ] right six
nine is still walking around so
i would like nine guards but yeah you
know they're shooting at rappers now in
atlanta you know uh
uh 42 doug and uh uh rich
uh uh roddy richards yeah that's nuts
that's crazy atlanta crazy yeah nuts i
know
you can't go to atlanta right now they
open though popping atlanta opening pop
can be an all-star game there
yeah oh it is coming up yeah oh
just wait next month wait no it's next
month march yeah next
next march yeah because you know he's
only playing 72 games oh got it right oh
how about the fights this weekend
mma in boxing did you see uh alex
yeah oh my god brunner looks what did
you think you didn't win that fight
you think so i didn't think you won that
fight i gotta agree with you he started
too late but i saw glimpses of old ab
but
i know but let me let me just be better
than you looking a long time but he's
still not like
he's not talking one judge i had it one
seventeen one eleven was crazy
he went to sleep he was like i bet on
the derrick lewis fight because he's a
four to one dog
and then my girl's like oh you can bet
on adrian broner because we're switching
that i'm like yeah i do not bet on
boxing yeah it's too corrupt yeah like
you can't
it's gonna go to the judges yeah yeah
they already have the favorite all right
because if you're gonna make money you
want to bet on the dogs hell no no he'd
win that fight
like did work that post interview clip
you said just cracked me up
did you send it to us yeah yeah yeah he
what do you say he said uh
they said what are you gonna do he said
i forget what he said he goes i was at
13 he said 13 13 million things are
going to change
yeah this is going to change yeah he was
like fleeing his chest
everybody what everybody doing checks
yeah cat i forget what he said having
sex
having something like that but i was
like damn bro you just got back so this
went to decision
yeah he could have stopped him because i
don't think he won that fight man either
way
they're setting them up for failure
because that fight doesn't say oh he's
ready for the top ten top five they're
going to give him some dog decks
yeah oh they're they are yes i can and
he's supposed to fight at one so who did
yeah who did he fight then
did he say who he want no i didn't say
anyone but again i'm pretty sure you
called somebody out i thought
i didn't get to that i just saw the
chicken that's his first one in four
years yeah i don't
know abs tough man i think there's a lot
of uh
mental health [ __ ] there i think it's
the good fight for him and again
we was talking about this jay and i um
what's
danny garcia that's a comeback coming
back
i don't think he beats danny i don't
think he's active enough to beat anybody
yeah yeah he needs like two more one
more thing everybody's telling showtime
he's like man
fight let me fight he's like so i stay
out of trouble he's like if i'm in here
i can't get in trouble out there so keep
me fighting
oh damn how old is he he's 31
31 32.
he's up he's up there and then uh yeah
the interviewer was like you know on
twitter they think you lost that fight
he's like twitter hates me who gives a
[ __ ] that is that's
no that's true now that's just where
bias is oh my god they hate him
they can't accept him except for uh
abner morris he was the only one
he was like give him a chance he's like
that jab was good he's throwing good
combos
but then even abner was real at the end
he was like i don't think he won that
fight
it's a good little clips from body shot
head shot but look look at that
uh poor san diego you'll never see him
again never like
never that was his one chance he did he
did good now i think i could throw him a
bone he'd be probably be a journeyman
for someone else like a champion
what does that mean journeyman like uh
basically he's going to be like to step
up like they say a prospect is going to
like want to go to the next level
he's going to be that guy that's that
that's the guy you got to get yeah you
got to fight
i think he might have he has like an
upset in him got good you know technical
skills with him
13 look yeah yeah brownish kind of side
he said rest weekend we're going to be
flipping bottles and have sex i'll be
back in the gym after this weekend
it's a long weekend baby i like it
bro he didn't lose he'll be the biggest
boxer ever yeah
oh my god he's [ __ ] hilarious yeah
he's so funny
he's so funny and it's good he's not
active enough or not yeah like in the
ring he's just you know
throw ten punches in a round why wasn't
he shot he's shocked though ever since
that marco's madonna knock
out you know that takes me the oh really
taking years off your life
was that before the pacquiao fight yeah
way before wave oh got it i think
there's a lot of mental health issues
because when i remember when he lost
that pacquiao fight he was like
he thought he won now he but it was
clear that was funny
that's a b just trolling oh he's oh he
was just trying to say he lost some
mikey garcia
and he took a lot of licks that fight
didn't throw any punches like after that
mark marcus
beat him up michael beat the piss out
yeah so it's just like he you know
years ago he getting hit in the head
like yeah cranium you got a little
concussion there buddy did you see the
knockout on espn
did i see it oh my god bro alex i knew
oscar bell
i still think uh cursed blade's knockout
was worse
then then oscars curtis was flat that
lined
uppercase knockout that was the knockout
i saw that yeah
yeah but now oscar on his back foot
throwing uh a hook was beautiful
and this boy was he was he's [ __ ] off
to hear that he's the underdog by the
way oscar
boom he's throwing him up he's [ __ ]
up the whole fight yeah
and then finally just put him away but
he like battered this poor dude
yeah and he was the underdog where's
that one though you'll see
he's coming yeah
it was [ __ ] yeah he got [ __ ] up he had
to go to the hospital didn't he
oh yeah i know i know you talk about
this one below the belt oh
god damn god damn yeah damn
that's the one back on the back plant
boom boom
dip dip check hook night night yep see
it
all right see it right here you're
already in position meet me oh
that was beautiful [ __ ] that was
beautiful he was asleep
he was asleep um we had a discussion i
know uh who's we
uh a couple of boxers though okay but
former
um the new age of boxing is different
because you see a lot of
punches you didn't see in the past is
getting like lee like like lead
uppercuts
no one ever threw lee uppercuts back in
like the 90s or the
2000s like nah but tyson would but they
gave me balls
the game involves now but it's like noon
like they're throwing a lot of up
because it's jabs now
so it's like a very unique like i sport
the other day with this guy
and it's like this new generation i
can't i'm like oh [ __ ] i gotta get out
i'm gonna comment
they're throwing uppercuts now like lead
up because instead of jabs they're
throwing hooks
i'm like goddamn like i'm talking about
check cause double three three hooks
yeah
so this new generator is like a jab yeah
so i'm saying
it's gonna be a lot more knockouts now
because you when you first start they
train
for the conditional what tactical
fighter like one two one two one two
threes one two uppercuts
now it's like yo you don't know what to
see everything is wild that's crazy
wonder if they're far more narco yeah i
don't know why you're spawning
uh i wonder if there is more knockouts
yeah there's more knockoff now
i don't i don't know is there a chin how
can we give me the
stats of not you're talking about like
big time typing year-to-year stats of
uh knockouts in boxing
like big fights though ufc's had two
walk-off knockouts back to back and
they're
bad man walk the wall uh back to back oh
back to back
i thought he said walk the walk
fifty percent of boxing match about
thirty percent that's not that's not
saying much
let's just take a look at this
boxes when was this jen i don't know
oh nevermind 2013. no that's not going
to work
what did you google your statistics of
knockouts in boxing
yeah i don't know if it's higher you
don't think oh
well just look at all the pay-per-view
fights the big fights in boxing
like uh the tank knockout this was a
knockout i'm not talking about bernie
because he's coming off of what two-year
layoff three-year layoff
uh the earl spence and danny garcia
danny garcia has a chin on him but he
could have stopped him
but he didn't he didn't you right uh i
don't even could have
okay don't let me cuddle knockouts um
tyson fury knocked out uh and he also he
was throwing like look what he was doing
though throwing wild punches and
you know wilder as well so he got wild
with them uh anthony joshua
i mean it's just so many people uh oh
derek derek just got knocked out by um
uh alex povecchi and another uh lead
uppercut
knocked him out slept yeah i wonder if
it is uh
so we had a discussion like yo this
boxing generation the fact that you
don't see like these punches like
throwing
like like as the lead elite uppercut is
a jab yeah but they'll adapt to it
just like everybody adapt to the other
stuff because there's only so much you
can do in boxing you only have two arms
that's true and that's it yeah but they
train mentally trained you like the one
two and stationary punches but now i'm
just saying it's gonna be more knockouts
i hope you're right boxing needs it yeah
it needs the knockouts
it's a great weekend for fights period
so why are you still sparring
yeah why are you sparring keep my stuff
tight i know but you don't make money
you don't make money doing that yeah but
you know wild card boxing you know
sometimes you go in there train hit the
bag a little bit and
you see the new guys coming up like yeah
you know glove up
so i glove up and uh yeah i get out
did you spar when you quit ufc never
dude my brain's mine you're like done
yeah hell no oh yeah girl don't matter
they say hey you're actually worse ct
what you mean the headgear increases it
because you you can take more shots
over with the head with the padding
let's say if you don't have headgear on
let's say we're
we're sparring mma the only way to do
this but if i had four ounce gloves on i
hit you
and you drop and we stop sparring then
you got the one hit
but if we're boxing a headgear on and i
hit you with that same punch and you can
take it but
you're not as wobbly you hit again you
get more concussion
and again more oh yeah hit it again
and then the realizing just the jab is
[ __ ] guys that was ct
like even the little ones you're like
like this yeah straight forward that's
straight up i'm glad i didn't fight
that's a tough girl yeah i'm glad i
didn't do that oh my bad cheerleading
was tight
headgear make sure to see so box camera
dodge as well perhaps take your
false sense of safety boxers take more
risks also makes the box's head bigger
target
the scene thing's a big deal i hate
wearing stupid headgear yeah yeah the
cnn oh you were getting a ring jim
no just before just just messing around
but i can't see that well so i'd rather
have
nothing at all so i can see every little
thing on the sides
it takes away your personal it takes you
away something and it's a towel so you
like this
yeah your hair big chance already i know
it's hot so you like this
look at him just even the tiniest thing
that makes it worse
even the tiniest thing make sure you hey
man i'll kick your ass that's what they
do
dog i'm over here hey man i'll kick your
ass like that that's what they do and he
got the nose guard as well you got a
nose guard yeah rock kick your ass
hell yeah yeah looking at you like this
but that's weird i didn't know
that uh concussions that's why boxing's
more dangerous than
mma yeah because if you get wobbling in
mma
your stop finish and they stop it boxing
you get an eight count
stand back up you already have brain
damage then you get more brain damage
and sparring you got to get up it's like
hold on i still need my work i've seen
so many people get knocked down and like
hold on wait done
damn it are you serious especially if
they pan them too man [ __ ] that
employee what's that [ __ ] y'all talking
about the dog house yeah the dog that's
what i'm talking about
though yeah the doghouse they bark it
they bark at you and [ __ ] or whatever
i saw somebody some dude in the dog i
was getting knocked down
and he was like hold on man nah nah
let's do it run it back and he literally
the first two punch boom boom got set on
and it was like nah that's enough he's
like hold on just give him some water
he'll be all right
are you serious hey guys that's that bro
yeah nope
nope cheerleading was fine okay so yeah
so snowboarding i used to go down there
with my family a big bear
and uh now we should rent a cabin and
they tell you to like you just
just like you know to break you got to
put like both feet in between but i was
twisting too well do you feed him
because i mean
yeah because in the middle that's how
you break that's how you you break in
the middle to slow down
what do you put your feet we know you
have the board fate like to slow down
you have the board face like
just sort of you gotta yeah it's like
horizontal horizontal yeah horizontal
yes then you push your heels in
to back yeah you did you not break once
when you're out there
yeah i did but you said something about
feet in between no your feet parallel
and your
your heels back and that's how you break
yeah okay you just
you're just saying it differently yeah
probably they said cross
sit cross your feet cross your feet
close your eyes
so you know when you stop you gotta
crash your feet
i mean i swear to god we gotta get you
some [ __ ] books
we gotta get a book i didn't say cross
between i said yeah y'all said cross my
head just say cross
i say you want your hips because you
know front and back la school districts
man they [ __ ] up they're tough out
here man
bro all right jim what do you guys got
tournaments
first one oh that's i got this from you
right recently it's from jay okay
you don't have to say that every time we
do a current event i don't know who's
gonna
just say thank you
i'm not gonna say it then but if it's
bad i'll say it's brendan's
you can do that you got it it's from jay
ou football player spencer jones starts
a fight with a smaller kid in a barn
gets his ass absolutely whooped turns
out the kid has done a ton of mma
training i haven't seen the videos there
they got a video of it
they're not
he's an ou football player oh look at
that little dude
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you take oh [ __ ]
ooh body like ew there's pee all over
the [ __ ] floor yeah
first of all that's the least of the
concerns of your passion gets back and
chokes them out damn
that's what you call getting a piss beat
out yeah
guys are still pissed he's a little dude
too
oh the guillotine
damn he has he has cowboy boots on
but this dude is [ __ ] this oh you
football player oh yo
oh damn that guy's getting really bad oh
wow bro
wait no no no it was one or more no both
of them were getting [ __ ] up
no no no because that's that dude's with
the no he's not he with the football
player
yeah the dude and the dude and the uh
jean jacket jean jacket he's getting
oh both of the homies are [ __ ] them
up oh okay
when you didn't ask for it you're like
why i understand
i have cowboy boots
jones picked the fight against a guy
with a decade a decade a 10 years of mma
training at ou bar this past weekend
it didn't end well for him you almost
lost his eye
he's currently coming from eye surgery
damn
spring football that was [ __ ]
gangster so wait it says oh boy well
would you look
scroll scroll please chin would you look
at that the kid even looked at his body
like man do we really have to do this
right now
yeah yeah but if they really want to do
this bro
i knew it was real cause when a dude
when he pushed him he did the nose
yeah he did that it was just a renegade
joke and punching bruce lee
he was like okay damn he should have
known when he did that little
bro he started hitting him with the
combos bro he didn't he didn't wait for
him no that's what you're getting
though man trying to be a bully on the
small yeah let me see that again
and that and he's bigger than that kid
oh way bigger
he laughed and he like broke you oh we
just rushed him
he hit his friend the whole time he goes
[Applause]
look you sure you ready watch this
oh
just getting roasted online now bro look
at this dude
laying a bubble jacket you have to have
eye surgery dude like wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa man just trying
to take a pig he should have gave him a
swirly
yeah oh yeah i was stuffed his head in
the toilet dude he's in
cowboy boots yes you remember the friday
afternoons with cat we was like hold on
working with a monster and then watch
homie gets slammed
i let a guy calling out the moose i
wonder why he let go the choke what do i
just shouldn't choke him to sleep i'm
not oh
i am dude they beat them they beat the
[ __ ] out of these boys
they [ __ ] gets oh dude that football
player didn't get one punch in
no you just defended himself he got
slapped in that fight
yeah nothing worse than you you could
tell his homie didn't want anything
because he looking in the mirror like
[ __ ]
was home no he didn't
recovering from eye surgery he looks
like a bully there
that mustache yeah yeah he got
his ass beat cost him his left eye
nearly costumed left eye you won't know
what he's a wide receiver he's a wide
receiver would you would you
uh oh he's a wide receiver yeah uh he's
on um he red shirt
a white wide receiver
he's tough to go
well that's why he's fighting running
for his respect and he's already
is he a registered player at all
yeah he definitely played yeah he's big
damn hold up
he just kept him his boys just got beat
up see he looks different right there
he's from nashville academic all big 12
first team honoree winner of the uh
hold oh he's the ho holder of the year
what does that mean all living games
so he's a holder for the kicker that's
when he's got it while he holds it for
the kicker
important job he played in all the games
and got beat up damn and he's a senior
this year
you know you say a senior a redshirt
senior yeah
yeah well wretched senior [ __ ] man what
does that mean registered
five-year player so you get four years
of eligibility redshirt gives you a
fifth year
oh god i got i got it well i think the
way you want to start your monday
no bro
oklahoma holder spencer joint jones
seriously injured in bar fight
god dude that's what i'm saying you
don't you don't know me when did he lose
his eye though because i'm seeing a boy
in the whole time
because probably when he mounted him he
was like oh yeah
man [ __ ] should be learning
[ __ ] right you don't know who you
messing with hold on it says uh in jones
version of events as he told the daily
by glass
he was trying to act as a peacekeeper
which doesn't have to match up with the
brief snip of the pre-fight conversation
you see in the video he was trying to
de-escalate the situation but
unfortunate it wasn't de-escalade
despite his best efforts
he became a victim of the vicious
assault you've seen i don't think he's a
victim whatever the intent is putting
your finger in someone's face while you
and your friend say look at me [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah it's not
really the way you so
he's playing victim on this he's trying
to but the video says otherwise
yeah he's asking right de-escalated yeah
he was all over dude he had one eye he
was like listen
i look like man wap look man i just dude
i bet he gets
roasted when he gets back to that locker
room oh [ __ ] that little boy in cowboy
boots beach up like
one eye now how you gonna hold the ball
for the kicker damn
he got that choking i know i know boy i
love how boy just kept looking at his
homie the whole time like man bro what
you thinking did he slap
[ __ ] i'm thinking what you thinking nah
that's not that's slap that's not
so disrespectful i don't listen i don't
know why you're uh
let's see the dr brooks came search
saying he's extraordinarily lucky at
this point he's like you didn't lose the
eye all together
wow that's what the goddess oh so he
[ __ ] that he broke his eye
uh orbiting orbital rebuild no orbital
socket things everything's eventually
come back to normal
it's gonna take a while for him to
recover that's for and for what dude
because you want to be an [ __ ] in the
bathroom also
he's a lot of people he has that liquid
courage though a lot of people are doing
mma man you know a lot of people [ __ ] a
lot of people dude
kenny floyd looks like a straight up
nerd pick a fight with kenny let me how
it goes for who's that
kenny flooring i don't think i know he's
an mma fighter
but he's like he looks like a nerdy dude
he will rock your [ __ ] world
damn there's a lot of nerdy guys that
are badasses man
like you'd pick a fight in a bar with
that guy no
[ __ ] no he's tiny you would i'm not
picking a [ __ ] no
we're not people oh no not you
personally clearly
i'm saying like if you're picking on me
i was like don't set me up
but he just looks like your average joe
yeah yeah
he kind of looked like sasha baron cohen
and he also kind of looks like a homie
that was in den of thieves
no that's our brother the other guy the
dude that's the villain
bro he look like the dea in snowfall no
i don't know any of these references but
uh yeah she stopped knocking
all right never heard it was like what
there's a few guys you don't want to
mess with first of all nerd
first of all as soon as i see the
cauliflower here i'm back in the [ __ ]
that's it all right you already know
yeah
right there that's the tail size some
don't have it though
oh really some don't have it not
everyone gets it you gotta be a vet
uh or just some people are more prone to
it i don't know if chase has any does he
do all the wrestlers do you can't tell
yeah you just
exactly that's the thing you can't
[ __ ] tell because everybody's going
to learn something and he got his curls
hiding his ears so yeah he's a little
bit every everybody out there learning
something i know
yeah my house whose street fights this
day and age
hey i prefer that i know
in the bathroom in a bathroom pissed all
over the floor this was all about
that's what i would have thought about
yeah
toilet paper on the floor hell now
speaking of piss can we take a break i
got a pig
yeah yeah let's take a little break from
the shenanigans because listen with
today's low
interest rates it's a great time to
refinance your student loans it's time
to break out of the student debt
cycle ernest can help you by refinancing
your student loan
times are tough worrying about your
student loan payments doesn't make
things
any easier that's why you need to
refinance with earnest
say goodbye to stressful student loan
payments take charge of your future with
earnest
earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing
and you can check your rate risk free in
just two minutes with earnest you get
radically flexible payments you can pick
your loan term all right
by refinancing you can reduce your loan
terms save money combine multiple loans
into one
simple monthly payment if you have any
questions can even talk to real life
human
at ernest for help isn't it time you
stop feeling overwhelmed by your student
debt
i know my family wishes that ernest is
offering you guys
a hundred dollar cash bonus refinance
your student debt
at earnest.com fighter terms conditions
apply
now ernest is giving you guys 100 bonus
refinance your student loans at
earnest.com
fighter terms conditions apply visit
fighter for more details terms
conditions apply earn a student loan
refinance made
by earnest operations llc and mls number
one two zero four nine one seven
california financing law license number
six zero five four seven eight eight
three oh three second street suites 401
north san francisco california
nine four one zero seven visit earnest
dot
for a full list of licenses earnest.com
fighter today's episode is also brought
to you by the kratom experts at super
speciosa
that's right we're talking kratom baby i
use it chin use it i don't do anything
without it i swear by this stuff
but it's the wild west you gotta trust
your supplier
that's why i linked up with
superspeciosa because i trust them i use
it every day i feel great
you don't have to worry about all the
bull shenanigans out there with kratom
they're a trustworthy brand unlike other
guys super specious it keeps their
kratom the way nature intended
all right it's pure baby it's pure
kratom
if you're gonna try kratom has to be
from super speciosa the rest of them
i can't vouch for super speciosa i can
and they're giving you guys 20 off go to
getsuperleaf.com
fighter that's get super l e a f dot com
slash fighter
and enter the code fighter for 20 off
that's getsuperleaf.com
code fighter snowboard is not something
you really
it's kind of like surfing you don't want
to just try it out once in a while well
like the thing
like everyone and everyone was like oh
you know because you skateboard you be
able to do but
skateboarding is just i thought the same
thing with surfing because i can
snowboard
i'll be good at surfing no skateboarding
skateboarding i can let go of the board
and like if i fall if i know i'm about
to fall you know how i know how to jump
off yeah yeah but like a snowboard
actually i'm strapped
i gotta fall with that big [ __ ]
i feel like skating would would relate
more to surfing
snowboarding to skating yeah okay maybe
because you can jump off you're not like
strapped you can skateboard right chin
that was gonna say like when i first
heard about snowboarding i told all my
friends
i can do it no problem because i skated
all these years yeah so i did it the
first day and i did do jumps the first
day my first time ever snowboarding oh
really yeah
i think some people some people just can
learn it faster how old were you then
were you 34
no i was older though are you older like
it's funny surfing is hard to get up on
a like surf center yeah
yeah it's a beast yeah i get that like i
was just like
this is completely different everyone
kept saying but like here's the thing
i know more people that could snowboard
than skateboard
what yeah yeah yeah that's true yeah as
far as like yeah being on the board and
like skating and like doing it it's
much easier it's just different i don't
i don't i can't escape
hell no cement
how about brian has been around me very
much he's like you dip now oh yeah
yeah i'm like where are you sorry we're
good we gotta we got it wrong
we're just gay
um back on wednesday
oh yes yeah can't wait let's [ __ ] go
he was in virginia beach this weekend
yeah
yeah he was out there i had a good time
the funny bone
yeah that virginia beats funny bones
what else you got jen
okay so uh authorities over in ohio
seized
a package of corn flakes because a
drug dog sniffed it alerted police
officers that there was something in it
this package was going from peru had a
layover in cincinnati and was headed
over to a
private residence in hong kong when they
opened it up they realized that it was
a bunch of corn flakes that were covered
in 44 pounds of cocaine
it was estimated to be about almost
three million dollars worth of cocoa
and is the cocaine's on the frosted
flakes they look like frost flakes and
they just taste yeah they try to pretend
like it was a sugar
holy [ __ ] that's incredible they get
creative yup
dog you know who's from cincinnati white
mike yeah adrian's town
adrian the only thing that didn't make
sense because uh i was in the car with
stevie while i was reading this he's
like
a few things didn't make sense to him he
said that the price of stephen coke
wasn't
like it wouldn't have had been three mil
and then he said it would have made
sense that they went from peru
to cincinnati so for him he said that
the situation suspect
very suspect very fishy so what do you
what is he assuming like
he doesn't know he just uh it's just on
that yeah it just didn't add up to him
stevie's in this ring too because like
that
uh there's a movie out now on the silken
road yeah oh
lion's gate shut up yeah i read the book
and so stevie's friends
with the dude who started the silk road
who's in prison for life
so if you know what the silk road is it
was kind of
you paying bitcoin he his idea was to
create an
amazon for like illegal [ __ ] like drugs
and all that stuff
so you know he started kind of the dark
web before his dark web and people can't
pay on bitcoin so it's hard for
detectives to figure it out to figure it
out he's like
you know it's tough there he is yeah
stevie's like super close he's a young
cat huh two life imprisonment terms
five plus 40 years so ross obrich
is the guy he shouldn't get life also a
guy that's smart
could you just hire him to work for us
for the government he's obviously a
genius
yeah he has like can he work with china
and russia so we they don't quit
hacking our [ __ ] 36 36 years he's worth
28.5 million that time of seizure
and how they caught him is interesting
too he uh
he would do everything from his laptop
okay and if he shut his laptop
he had a system in place where we shut
it everything went away
you couldn't get into it so these cops
someone ratted him out was like he goes
to this
coffee shop in san fran every tuesday at
9 00 a.m
so the cops found out he was gonna be
there a cop pretended that he was like
just
drinking coffee that was like undercover
working on his laptop
and asked the dude he's like hey can you
hand me that thing and he went to go
handle the thing and he grabbed his
laptop
and that's how you got caught well look
at his prison photo two years with the
homies i'm sorry
uh two life terms terms plus 25. look at
them with the homies bro posted up
[ __ ] two life terms dog damn what prison
is that where all the ethnicities going
i want to say almost this is a fake
photo no no
it's not it's it's non-violent oh
that's non-violent drug defense yeah
it's cool when it's not violent yeah
they
they probably dude i mean the rest of
your life in prison for starting a dart
where he gets dicey with him and stevie
always defends it
where it gets dicey with him is uh
there was a also another owner of the
the site that he would like give shares
to
and then that guy want to do some and
then the detectives again
who knows what really happened but
detectives made it seem like he was
trying to kill that kid
he's trying to hire somebody on the the
silk road to kill that guy
oh to kill this it's kind of kind of
like the joe exotic [ __ ]
murder for hire i don't think you should
spend prison and for the rest of his
life that's insane i'm definitely going
to watch the movie
but again same directors who did um
night stalker yep that nice talking with
uh
jay so is it a film film or a
documentary
oh okay based off this
gotta watch that stevie's all do you
want his mom on the show i'm like um
coke on corn flakes is crazy that is
crazy they've done weird [ __ ] before
yeah
some of these things are super creative
you have to be but
it's so much what detective was like
this is a shitload of corn flakes man
yeah like reached into the thing it was
all
[Laughter]
over here i love how he tried to realize
a
[Music]
okay so cam newton over the weekend was
visiting
a football camp that he uh helped create
it he
funds anyone to go out to support the
kids kind of be there as
morale and there was a kid who was
attending the camp
talking [ __ ] to cam newton calling him a
free agent
and the internet was basically reacting
are you a free agent can you
what yeah you're phrasing i'm rich yeah
and he's
super that's it he paid yeah
he was also mvp of the league yeah it's
the kid was just being a troll
he was just trying to go viral and then
cam and like
all these other athletes got on their
defending cam the kid got lit up on the
internet like him trying to go viral
he went viral for the wrong for the
wrong [ __ ] social media wasn't like
yeah way to go kid they're like
can you imagine getting an opportunity
to chat to cam newton and you use it
nevertheless before
and also what people don't realize is
all those kids at that camp that won't
be professional football players hate to
tell you odds are
none of you will even make it division
one college let alone winning heisman
like you did
let alone make the nfl be the number one
pick let alone not only make it to the
nfl
be the mvp of the nfl yeah he's one of
one man and he's a heisman trophy winner
did you yep said
he said that oh he said that he said
that but a lot of people are uh giving
this kid a lot of flack because they're
saying that he's
yeah because cam gives back to the
community that he's from
he's constantly there trying to help
improve everyone's lives
where he came from and so this kid is at
his camp
benefiting off of him and trying to go
viral yeah it's so different and then uh
all athletes came out and leonard
fournette uh
super ball winner for the tampa
buccaneers running back but any young
athlete watching this video please don't
be this kid don't miss your chance to
learn something from someone who has
been
there at the highest level in this sport
stay humble
he's so right man these [ __ ] idiot
kids
that's kids to date over what was your
take though my take was
okay so cam got up upset and this kid
this kid's like bro
i was just talking [ __ ] what happened to
the the
giving it back back and forth like
football is like talking [ __ ]
it's not though it's not he doesn't it's
never that they don't know each other
but but also
also this isn't another it's not like
teenagers teenager
dude when i was a kid i remember i did
uh the ed mccaffrey camp
i would no no no kid in their right mind
would talk [ __ ] to him
to the nvp like what do you you're in
high school
yeah like i'm sorry what what what
stance are you
what's your stance what are you a
starter on your high school football
team
yeah talking [ __ ] it's not like he was
like talking [ __ ] as another
professional athlete
that's whatever you can do that you're
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're in
high school yeah bro you ain't
[ __ ] get some accolades first you ain't
get some [ __ ] not even you're going
you're a free agent and cam's like
i'm rich what are you talking about yeah
i'm rich what
he's just he's never even touched cam's
level no no
so first and foremost this is the kid
okay yeah i'm gonna write this but here
we go
first and uh foremost i want to express
my deepest apologies cam newton my
entire
organization my coaches for my actions
at the seven verse seven tournament this
past weekend
i did not intend for it to get as far as
it did first i would like to start off
by saying my parents
never taught me uh to people
disrespectful as a football player i let
my competitive competi what competitive
side
no this is like you know it's insane it
was a myth a moment and i realized how
a lot of you took it as disrespect yeah
yeah never mind accumulate and let
anyone down
i'm very appreciative for the community
yeah you talking about the where he
gives back
yeah i realize this can uh dictate my
future as young man having very big
goals dude you're never going to make it
uh but i will not allow this to stop me
from getting where i need to be it will
so again i apologize and hope i can be
forgiven
they said i hope i hope don't matter
listen i hope the
chance of him make it are still 0.0001
yeah it's middle
let's nvp you are you're talking [ __ ]
to the nfl mvp yeah the first round
draft pick yeah
the guy who won a national championship
at auburn won the heisman what's up
you know how many guys when heisman then
go on to win mvp yeah are you out of
your
[ __ ] mind yeah and cam newton demon
want to engage
engage with him yeah where's your dad at
let me talk to your dad yeah
yeah yeah exactly and you know and i
hope like yeah cause at the end of the
day
he is still a kid right so i hope like
he is able to like
does that does that affect his like
because again they said he was nice does
that affect his draft like coaches look
at him like oh he's a problem already
like going to like these colleges i
don't think so if he's good
he's not gonna put up with it yeah you
know how many guys are nice though
a lot of people there's tons yeah well
i'm just saying that so my thing is he
he even has
we don't know how good it is you know he
even has the wrong attitude going into
this
seven on seven years yeah yeah so if you
have an attitude going to seven on seven
community
that's your birthday dude trust me
there's way nicer people out there
yeah that's what i'm saying i don't
think so if he's like undeniable they're
still i mean
i don't know i would still recruit him
hopefully he learns from it yeah just
what a [ __ ] hopefully
yeah super how many nfl players how many
nfl mvps how many heisman trophy winners
do you meet where you talk
[ __ ] but that's the internet and he
thought oh this is what we do
and then everyone's like it's not what
we do so his only accolade is looking
bad on camera
against a form i think he thought he'd
go viral talking [ __ ] to cam newton he
thought
like because online people should on cam
he thought everyone's like yeah way to
go and they're like oh
oh this ain't the way to do it yeah
because you ain't [ __ ]
you ain't [ __ ] you trying to get to
where cam is yeah
yeah like for cam like you won't even
entertain it
that's nice that's like fan fan type
[ __ ]
people that are fans of football and
[ __ ] like yeah that's that kind of
[ __ ] energy
not someone that's like trying to
[ __ ] eventually become
yeah now if you want yeah exactly
if you even if you have cam talent i
don't think you even like belittle
yourself to go at cam like that if i was
out there bawling i'm like like cam yeah
yeah yeah but it's back now if another
mvp like criticized cam
then i'm sure cam would debate with you
but because he's been in his shoes you
debate with us like lamar jackson lamar
jackson goes up to him like bro you
ain't no you respect him because lamar
jackson well he's he's made it he's
there
yeah this kid is trying to get the
height to [ __ ] vision one college
yeah
at a seven o'clock oh he's he's 19 is
that what they said he was he's a he's a
high schooler
high school at 19. well he's 19. i think
he's 19. he's a kid yeah he's a kid bro
i bet he's just getting belittled
probably a wake-up call for him too yeah
probably good for him
hopefully they don't go too hard on it i
know he's still a kid yeah
[ __ ] they don't you know the internet
doesn't show remorse [ __ ] the internet
just people in general like
in the past but his homies probably you
know
[ __ ] all that well this is video right
here i think so this one right
yeah two minutes long nah i saw that so
a lot of people do the
uh smaller clips but this is a different
angle we go to the beginning
[Music]
today
he got speed
it was cocky
someone said he's talking [ __ ] as crocs
this is after the initial uh yeah
if i was his [ __ ] coach and his coach
trying to talk to him
he's coach talking to him right now it's
a grown man
[Music]
own way oh boy was but again you can't
turn it off like i'm trying to talk to
you he's like man you're gonna see
yeah i know it's like bro i'm trying to
talk to you listen how are you gonna
impress oh man
man perspective this guy's a little boy
and he's still in his mindset so he's
like man i don't know him he's spitting
i've been there before you spitting in
front of someone you nervous yeah he's
sitting there spitting i'm like
yeah cause every the attention is on you
he didn't want that smoke
you know like he's like grown man
conversation imagine being an open mic
or saying some [ __ ] to bill bird
and then he calls you out from there all
the comments from all the comments yeah
you got [ __ ] to [ __ ] say
and he's spinning but this even like
being like uh open micro talking bill
bird this would be like being a
a person who bought a ticket to bill
bird's free show
and then talking [ __ ] yeah yeah that's
why you're special in [ __ ] and you're
like
do you have a special yeah but yours was
[ __ ] that's fine
but do you have a special yeah no i'm
i you know i want to be okay what we're
not in the same lane dude
that's why you can't put any energy
unless someone's
in your shoes they're in the same path
you put zero energy into it
zero yeah i couldn't imagine talking
[ __ ] to a cheerleader way better than me
what's the exact what's that snow at
least you're a cheerleader at least at
least i'm a cheerleader this kid's not
right like you know what i'm saying like
at least
it's just insane yeah yeah man
this one okay so a bunch of people
submitted and said that they wanted you
guys to react to
crystalia's video because it came out
last week and brian also came back onto
the show last night friday night yeah
you said to the group chat yeah i sent
to you guys i thought
um i thought i thought it was best case
scenario i thought he
nailed it as far as like an apology
thing and just giving everybody an
update and just letting people know like
you know he's been getting help which he
has i talked to chris every week
he's been getting help and uh just
taking necessary steps to
to come back man and i think it's weird
too it's like
you know obviously a year away from work
from making a dime off his talents
it's like how much do you want to punch
punish the guy
and and what when what uh what
what charges were pressed yeah i'm i'm
waiting what charges were pressed on
brian
or chris yeah what charges do you have
yeah you bring me charges
with different conversations different
conversations were you talking about
rumors and
what are we gonna what are we supposed
to do what are you supposed to do
can't come on his own show for for how
long we give him a basically a year off
a year of discipline i talk count every
single day
that's what else is interesting it's
kind of like you know
with that um cesa hotel thing where all
these youtubers thought
oh this this and this the texture like
you guys don't have the facts you don't
know what you're talking you don't know
what you're talking it's fun to talk
about yeah same thing with me and brian
oh brent threw brian under the bus
brandon kicked brian off the show well
you guys have no clue
i talked to brian every single day we
had a plan
you seen it come to fruition brian was
getting compensated every single day for
not being here
because what happened to him was out of
my control out of his control
so we we there's no book on how to do
this yeah
but you can see we had a plan chris has
a plan
we're all we all have conversations that
you guys don't get to see
because you're not our friends and it's
not for the public straight up that's
straight up right there
they're not our friends exactly the
[ __ ] point right right chris wasn't
coming out with this video
i knew why chris wasn't talking i knew
why chris wouldn't do his podcast
i knew why chris wasn't doing stand-up i
knew why brian decided to leave
fighting the kid i knew why brian was
doing this other stuff i knew why brian
was doing this this and this
you guys don't know they don't know but
everyone has their conspiracy yeah
there's an idea
yeah because it's more fun it's more
yeah
no one knows how to deal what they dealt
with no there's no blueprints yeah what
do you do we try it we try to
i think humans we always say this like
the truth yeah we care about the truth
but the lie is more exciting
it seems like it is it's so fun we can
just pick you people
it's fun to say oh brent brendan kicked
brian off the podcast
no that's the whole thing brian owns 50
of the show if brian if brian wanted to
yeah if legally he'd go i'm not going
anywhere
and i in in the advertising okay we're
not coming the podcast brian can
still go that's fine i'm not going
anywhere i don't have to show and i
would be like yeah you don't have shows
would
if you want to sit here go ahead yeah
but the plan was
brian's gonna take an absent until
things get more clear
and advertisers are cool with them
coming back that's brian's plan all
right that's what you want to do you do
that brian
while you do that i'm going to have
chappelle malik fill in
and let's figure it out until then he
goes yep good idea
he's never done this before because this
gives me a good opportunity to build my
own brand
because i've always relied on other
people now i can do my own shows like
you do yep do that yeah
i'll carry this i'll hold this down and
then when you feel comfortable come back
you come back
that's so dope last week brian texted me
hey man i think it might be time to come
back
you don't have to show they have such a
great response you want to come back
come back
yeah and people loved it people had a
really good response with brian coming
back
had a great response when chris dropped
that video
if again if you have charges and there's
actual charges filed
yeah brian can't come on the show chris
can't come back
sure you show me those and i'm and i'm
going to say it's a different [ __ ]
story
but there's nothing yeah there's nothing
so what yeah exactly
so it's like what the [ __ ] do you what
do you want well you tell me what like
what's the price that brian
and chris should pay yeah i'm pretty
hefty price for what they've dealt with
brian can't be can't come on the show
chris
couldn't do his can do his stuff
social media like you said you guys are
not my friends
yeah you don't know yeah they don't know
but i love the positive
messages and oh yeah he got he got a lot
of positive uh
i thought i thought his apology was
great honestly yeah it made my
very own it made my friday i texted him
oh
right it made my i called him yeah
i had to yeah yeah i just yeah likewise
and
in here and here's the other thing is
you know people are like oh why isn't
chris come why isn't chris doing his
podcast wasn't he touring
well because what chris dealt with you
know how hard is to be funny right now
yeah for him what do you want to what do
you want me
yeah she found out all this stuff mm-hmm
he just became a father too
just became a justin and you know what
there's light then a tunnel for him too
because it made him realize what's
important and his family's important
we're going to talk about a guy doubling
down on his kid
that's crystalia double down on being a
dad
spends every morning puts his son to
sleep put wakes him up
he's always with his kid the thing me
and chris talk about most are
our kids that's what we relate to most
now that's dope and so i don't know if
that would have happened you know chris
lived in a fast life
i don't know if that would happen if he
didn't have to go through this
i do think chris comes back i do think
he'll be funny again
i do think he'll be one of the top torn
comics in the world
how how long what do you guys want to
see from you know
same with brian there's light up in the
tunnel for those guys
yeah yeah man i love that and where's
light there's power
i don't even know what you're talking
about
[Laughter]
so a couple of women dressed up as old
women to get their coronavirus shots
and they actually got the first shot
because you know it's it's always panic
and it's just
the organization is terrible right now
with the app and all that stuff the
worst
yeah so they were able to get their
first dose but then the second dose they
noticed that they're wearing wigs and
fakes you know all that stuff to make
them look older and they looked at their
actual id because they gave them their
real ids and showed that they were 34
and 44.
have you see again this is there's so
much [ __ ] gets thrown to the wall during
covert times i'm not trying to spread
rumors
but i heard from a legit doctor that now
it's actually going to help us because
you only need that first dosage you
don't need they're saying
with scientific because it's fairly new
and like you need two to defend it
now they're saying that first one
protects you from 97 of the virus so the
thinking you need just the first one now
but we we have all these double kids so
now we're gonna have double the dosage
to give people the first vaccine
yeah oh [ __ ] so it could even speed up
things
yeah yeah because they they think half
of the united states has hurt immunity
and then the rest we can vaccinate yeah
wow so john hopkins experts thinks will
be wide open by
april oh that'll be dope i know you know
again there's a lot of science out there
there's a lot of agendas from these big
pharmacies and the government so who
knows
well hopefully it's uh legit
all right so this is a content creator
she does like a fashion blog and then
there's a huge fashion blogger she has
like two point something million
followers
and then this girl is saying that she's
jacking her styles like almost
immediately afterwards i'll show you
this one real quick did the small time
person make a thing
yeah there's a small time person talking
about the big one
she ain't small time now
don't wear that though
very similar i got a lot of attention
for it because it seemed like
pretty much copying and i kind of
brushed it off because it was like
you can wear that top in so many ways
like maybe she just saw it and took
inspiration whatever
but yesterday i posted this photo and
i'm so proud of it i bought a new
fisheye lens i
made my boyfriend take them in the same
corner of my room and i've been taking
my photos
and then literally minutes ago danielle
posts it
weird it's almost
if she would have just put my name in
the caption that would change my life
2.3 million people to see my name and
see that like she's taking inspiration
for me that would be
life-changing and it's just so unfair
that she just keeps taking
inspiration well that was pretty much it
and then
so you can see it there and then someone
straight up jacking her style did she
ever
pay homage no so this one she said looks
very familiar this is the small one
right yeah and then someone replies
i thought this was you and then she the
actual famous one
wrote this haha except i'd never seen
that girl's profile before but so cute
great minds
she probably never saw her profile but
because someone
yeah yeah whoever hurt her yeah her
people she's pretty hot too
and uh this is a picture this is one
picture she i think she could delete
another one but then she puts no
comments yeah turn the comments off yeah
interesting yeah is it only those two
i think so but then they're saying that
she takes it from other people too
if you're you know if you're a jokes
dealer you steal from one that's kind of
cool yeah that's what it reminded me of
like a joke stealer
yep yikes um so i saw a couple of these
i thought were funny because texas i
mean this is a funny part of the texas
thing which is a tragedy
but people are slipping so there's this
one here
his boy is all making fun of him look at
this
i like how he just stayed down
this boy's like damn duck
[Laughter]
but that's his girl though yeah oh baby
oh that's
the natural reason yeah that black
ice son yeah
texas a little bit of trouble listen i
love texas no hate on texas
they're in a bit of a [ __ ] storm with
that stuff man this ain't a quick fix
either
and then people's uh electric bill some
guys elect your bill just to stay
another one is like seven thousand
dollars and then the electric company's
like sorry you owe us that money it's
like no no
the reason is so high is because your
government [ __ ] up and wasn't ready
for this
and forced to stay alive we gotta we
gotta we gotta keep
everything on this guy's was seventeen
thousand dollars and that's i guess they
work off a shared grid so if
like you know that's they're just
sharing the actual power but since
everyone's power's out here
he took the brunt of all the the power
so they charge them this much so
they're actually going to try to like
obviously there's a person there's no
way he can leave because that's insane
you can't leave the people of texas on
the hook for this i mean why
it's because your poor planning that
this is the happening yeah
why even send the [ __ ] bill because
why isn't that going to use
america it's probably automated too it
is automated bills right
yeah but 17 000 is crazy skyrocketing
energy costs yes it ain't right they'll
get it they'll get it right though yeah
they get right it's horrible when you
hear about people freezing to death and
kids and [ __ ] man you heard about this
woman died in a car yeah
oh yeah in a garage but it was like her
and her family right
i thought carbon monoxide poisoning
carbon monoxide poisoning but there's
also like an eleven-year-old and his mom
froze the dog
in a motor home it's horrible dude yeah
man like a
trailer park yeah it's horrible all
right so elise 1980
tagged us all in this have you seen this
one yes i saw this
i haven't seen this watch this it's
crazy that gut thought
[Laughter]
he was like whoa yeah how did i see that
you got to cheer that [ __ ] home
i did not
know he was going to complete that i
can't believe it didn't break yeah yeah
i thought that was the video it's going
to break i thought it'd break
floyd mayweather gifted his
granddaughter grandson grandson
right grandson a rolex a baby size rolex
that's like so cute it's all hands and a
fist
that's cute as [ __ ] that is i love how
the comments that's like a 100 million
dollar rope
i love how the comments was like man
this is a bad gift you should
you want to help your grandson give him
like put that money in like
wealth and all that good point but i
mean let the man spend his money on how
you want to spend his money
yeah around 32 000 euros
that's not too bad he has a massive
watch collection doesn't yeah yeah
yeah he's a beast
shout out to floyd man um
this one was interesting glenn maxwell i
guess she told she somehow slipped to a
director
doing some sort of or a producer that's
helping to write a book
that there's secret tapes of donald
trump and bill clinton at epstein's
place jesus christ
claiming to have heard it straight from
her mouth yeah he was able to like trick
it to
trick her to giving him that information
wow dude think how [ __ ] trump would be
if that
and bill clinton if that gets out there
yeah yo
i mean yeah
and let's see the last one let's do this
so there was a uh a blizzcon virtual
metallica set so
you know blizzard entertainment the
video game company oh yeah they're
really big they're out here
they're on burbank yeah yeah uh there's
also one in like irvine too
so they had a concert virtual concert
but then they use twitch to to show the
concert
but twitch also has a homepage where
they kind of wanted to show the concert
too
but then the last minute they freaked
out and like no we can't do it because
metallica
use metallica's music they copyright you
right away yeah metallica is one of the
one bands that does not play like you
know
you can basically walk out to any song
except metallica
and you see the beatles right yeah they
don't they don't let you
metallica does not play they won't use
their [ __ ] any facet
you if you post like let's say you post
one of your tour like dates
you put a metallic song it will get
pulled down faster than anything
damn you get pulled down faster than you
post on a dick pic metallica does not
play
garth brooks kind of was like that too
i'm not sure if he's changed but he you
can never buy his music anywhere other
than
starting start with really starting yeah
it started with that snaps her
metallica's
yeah so so even though it was on twitch
twitch's homepage
they freaked out they didn't want to do
it so they were still streaming on
twitch but twitch couldn't do it on
their
website so they freaked out and they put
music over them
and that's the funny part of this i'll
play it for you
so they would just play this entire
music that's for that song they'll play
that kind of music over here
i was listening to black sabbath this
weekend that's what's up
yeah that is what's up that's awesome
right that is what's up yeah
oh my god oh my god there's so much
fish on this menu bro
he was just like i was like wow he was
just all white
just there like mac was indifferent
because i was like yo
i know you're getting that chicken she's
like no he's not
he's getting the swash blossoms i was
like
swash blossoms no he's not
they're not i got enough we're talking
about valley beach talking about no i'm
not getting the chicken come on
with the sea bass right malik well you
know
i love it i love sea bass that was weird
that was fun that was funny because
you're like man you get the chicken he
didn't say that
he didn't say that he goes
like so brittany's on the opposite side
of the table we're having a conversation
i guess she was drifting off about how
white she was
he comes out of nowhere hey molly you
getting the chicken right i see
she was like malik you eat chicken baby
i'm getting a salmon you know
she
i've never seen brendan so uncomfortable
by a white person in my life
yeah you know the only white person at
that table was my curse
yeah we're all set on white people
she said that's like this place is
adorable
i shouldn't do that [ __ ] it is funny
because you're all like
polar opposites oh man yeah you your
girl because she's
i got me a thug
jody wanna [ __ ] is that how you say it
shorty is that my i say it right now
oh shoddy oh that's fun
oh i like that i like that
she's on youtube hey she's on tick-tock
and then where to come she long
doing the dances and [ __ ] she does a
little
she looks at you she's alone
she's
not in here
[Music]
should we go out there and [ __ ]
protest no no we should go out there
we should go out there because what are
we doing in here
we need to be out there you need to be
hurt because frankly i'm sick of this
yeah
no no take my hand we're going now now
you got your mask you got your mask
right you got your you literally blm on
it
oh god
was having a whole conversation with her
he go how you getting the chicken right
she was like no why didn't you say that
no they killed chickens they cloned
chickens now
yeah i was in big bear uh [ __ ] you every
winner
and i got a big book bear book book bear
book bear
book bear book bear moms yeah i will not
be in book bear while being in tampa
florida
this friday and saturday two shows
friday two shows saturday
planet at a show so stay tuned for that
tickets on f a
tkz.com uh in two weeks i'm in cleveland
ohio march 11th through the 13th
cleveland ohio hilarities
then after that i will be in spokane
washington march 18th through the 20th
then after that miami florida march 25th
to 27th
get your tickets at f a t k z dot com
right now that's it man chabelle you'll
be in canada
yeah this weekend man february this
friday and
uh through saturday comedy club of
kansas city
mystery i'm speaking like malik right
now sorry that's thursday though right
uh yeah thursday through saturday uh get
those tickets right now send me those uh
healthy food recommendations what time
do you leave on thursday you know uh
what time i leave thursday
i think in the morning why what's up
y'all trying to work out no
no what's how you leave i leave thursday
afternoon i think i leave thursday at
like 10.
oh you was trying to pop an episode damn
that would be tough that'd be hard
well see you this weekend kansas kansas
city go see chapelle go get that lover's
type merch man that's
uh brendan's got a hoodie i gotta get
him what these [ __ ] want from
uh what'd you say i'm gonna step on the
scale
just take your shoes off no it's 279
it's the elevation as well let's write
270 let's say 276 this is a slant right
here i'll give myself two things is
there a slime yeah
it's a slant right here so it's kind of
easier to cut all that weight
is there any faster yes or no maybe we
just put it right here
let's see this one this should be better
all right
that makes sense all right go ahead how
is everyone heavier
because it was on the side it was on the
side slightly
right there but this might wait so am i
the 270 let's see we'll do it again
we'll do it again hold on do it on us
okay keep moving i know
i got this i got this can i step on that
gimpy
thank you guys i don't know all right
here we go
where are you at hell yeah how would it
go up five people muscular build up
was it i know yeah that ain't right
legit 178 all right come here come here
now you step one 178
but why is it calculating weight
depending there it is right here
oh 275 yeah because it's the elevation
this is flat right here
where are you 267
272 so you're 265. i'm 265 yeah yeah
oh okay so that's the way you're in spot
check how much how much do you weigh 185
uh 275 and mine was one thirty seven
don't hurt him
oh we gotta do shoe cam sorry every bit
of 270.
all right two no i'm just saying i
thought 250
you were no no yeah you're right i'm not
255. but it's all good man
it's all good i'm working on it boys263
yeah i worked my ass off
yep what's up they call me chappelle
ac275 is what i weigh
and uh this is the vans baby you know i
can't and also shout out to uh
bradley's raw gear um shout out to those
fans for carrying all that weight
like bugs
oh i'm 180 shut up now they be they
ain't believing me
180 right here i'm wearing like the
doughboy air forces
regular all white i went to old school
chevy's to drop top
porsches wouldn't walk a mile underneath
my air forces
263 even on malik's [ __ ] scared wait
wait wait no it's not voicing that fake
karen scale
his girl bought him that target it's not
real no it's not still 263 on there
down nine they're dirty
i'm putting this on a scale in your
pocket